hey there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm a turd in the wind we are gonna
watch a couple of things from here we go
guys before we go into that I wanted to
say thank you to everyone who's been
joining our patreon page patron on get
your patron on.com yo we got TV show
reactions what what attack on titan my
hero academia do we also have Gotham do
we have
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Sheehan
Riverdale and supernatural and we got
skip you and A's man we just post so
much over there would love it if you
became a patron oject today let's get
into this started with the exclusive
clip that's making the waves today it's
38 seconds long oh boy
Eddie Brock ambitious Carlton drink I've
been waiting for this if you're gonna
release a clip of venom yeah I always
believe space exploration is crucial you
know our quest to cure everything veils
us here on earth how does that work you
know exactly the life foundation thing
how does it how does it how does it go
about say testing pharmaceuticals Eddie
I'm talking about the allegations it
says that you recruit the most elegant
of us to volunteer for tests more often
than not end up killing people thank you
we're not finished this you want mr.
Brock is that a threat have a nice life
scene felt heavily cut down now think so
no no I think it's gonna play out
exactly like that and I hope it lasts
only that long too so we can just get to
some venom action right away
I hope all scenes in the movie feel just
like that one you know what I got from
this I think top part is gonna do a
really good idea Brock yeah there's
something about the way he was talking
just be like I don't know you know it
seemed like just so naturally a
conversation there we go that's my one
reliable piece of hope for this movie is
like no matter how the rest turns out I
feel like Tom Hardy can just provide a
well lived in carry on regardless like
he's so good at feeling natural and
doing the mannerisms well I mean I got
some further opinions to make about that
um after this we cannot just eat people
[Music]
is there something you might tell me
you worship our home
my eyes wait did you just like survive
either guy so so he almost date a guy
but then they they cut they cut away a
kayak before you need that pg-13 rating
and the directors already talking about
having an r-rated cut come out oh damn
it
which is a good sign to have let's give
that petition going let's start that
petition look guys Schneider cut while I
have you know hope for this movie and
while I think that Tom Hardy will do a
good job in the film I just get the
impression overall you know like even
though there's been some shreds I got me
really excited the more I hear about
this movie and the more I rewatched the
trailers and everything like this
probably is gonna be a good movie I feel
like I'm gonna be like cheesy in the
wrong ways I feel like it best this
movie's gonna come out as one of those
films it's really weird and not without
its merits but also not a successful
rendering of the subject matter than
trying to put up on screen I'm getting
the impression it's gonna be weird and
all the ways that it shouldn't be weird
yeah it should be if anything weirder
but it's not gonna go full weird it's
just gonna be weird in the way it's
composed and put together I have a
feeling we're in for an uneven movie
with a battle of conflicts of what they
wanted to do with the film yeah I feel
like that pg-13 is gonna feel a bit
intrusive the thing that also worries me
is like even in looking up the different
teasers and ads for this video we're
shooting now most all of them borrow
from all the same footage just mixed in
a different order and so that makes me
worried for this because even when
they're like oh we're gonna see some new
stuff in this trailer it's one shot
maybe yeah you know or two shots I feel
like at best it's gonna be cheesy
entertainment yeah yeah yeah it's kind
of all I expect which I could be down
for I could go for a b-movie in a way
the main reason they wanted to make it
pg-13 was for the hopes that venom could
cross over into the MCU just with the
vibes of getting from this I don't think
it's gonna be
that good of a movie to war into that
crossover I honestly don't think it
would hurt their chances of a crossover
if they made this rated are because for
me the caveat would just be you come on
to MCU territory then you're gonna be in
a pg-13 environment and if it's in a
protagonist II kind of way I mean they
can easily address that by being like
okay don't eat anyone's head yeah you
know and if it's in an antagonistic kind
of way I'm sure they can find a way to
make him fit in with me yeah well I
don't really see pg-13 as giving them
all that big of a chance for a crossover
because if the movie doesn't work
because of that it's all moot anyway
there's Isis here Michelle Williams talk
for a second though telling people
always released these movie clips of
these films that are all 9 times out of
10 edited for the internet they might
cut off a piece of information or
they're just trying to rush it it's so
apparent that this venom exclusive clip
is not the way it's gonna play out it's
so choppy to the point of there's
there's no way I believe that the worst
that part is if that is the actual
equipment oh man worried as hell but I
don't I don't believe at all that that's
the actual clip of the movie
no it's they sliced up a clip why yeah
thing is what they did show us doesn't
add anything new to what we already saw
from that scene in the trailer it adds a
couple more lines of dialogue it's
essentially the same thing but yeah you
still know that he's poking where
Carlton Drake doesn't want him to poke
in this interview that going well and
this is gonna create a conflict between
the two of them no new information if
anything the marketing strategy on this
clip is there's a terrible idea
see the problem is that I you know there
are so many different ways to think and
I am starting to get an amazing
spider-man 2 vibe or it's like they're
showering us in these different TV spots
and clips and stuff like that and I
gotta wonder if they're just really
trying to blitz that opening weekend
don't worry dad amazing spider-man vibe
since day one from the footage that was
released from the teaser that had no
venom yeah like that one from this feels
so Sony yeah it does
yeah fingers crossed I guess though yeah
man like the trailer sir gotta be
excited before but there's something
about when I rewatched them on my own
and especially the last time I saw the
trailer in the theaters I was like you
know I've been like positive and
optimistic the business could do
something but lately like way after we
filmed the velocity reactions I'm like
there's something that's not clicking
for me and in the landscape of superhero
stuff right now I feel like this might
end up is just some sort of weird
sideshow attraction easily you know like
I can imagine this being a very distinct
movie the one thing I don't expect it to
be I guess is generic but distinct
doesn't always mean good anyway with
that being said I'll wrap this video but
given a picture of the day shout out to
a man named Joshua Lucero Joshua is a
man who I haven't really talked to
lately but he's been a loyal patron to
us and he lives all the way in Hawaii he
you know he's a really kind guy to the
Hawaiian community teaches soccer to
kids and everything but a while ago when
we last talked all the way back in July
actually he was telling me how he's a
man who's been married for eight years
to a hot-ass woman I'm assuming she's a
woman I assume they could have adopted
who knows
nah sighs Joshua style not Josh his son
doe his name is Jarek that's Jarek with
a Y and he's only ten years old
Jarek is actually a big fan of the
channel had no idea and I gotta tell you
man the kind of jokes that we sometimes
make here and the kind of language I
want you to know Jarek that I am so
sorry you can be sorry don't just be
sorry I think it's okay to totally take
it into the schools start using
vulgarity everywhere you go I think your
dad and mom would agree with me on this
that if you make perverted commentary
commit as far as you can go just do it
making people uncomfortable especially
your age is with leads to getting laid
before your third
all facts Joshua I think sure we've
earned you increasing your pledge buddy
yes yeah this for Sage whiz that swai
you come to patreon really is for the
sage wisdom like this you want you to be
a motivational speaker for your kid how
merry guy yeah you want us to help you
raise this child I mean you've got to
show us that you're invested a matter of
fact if you want me to go to your soccer
team and talk to those kids
I got years of advice I could give oh
yeah totally we're gonna totally turn
them around I mean none of the advice
worked for me but it'll work for these
kids could work for these kids subscribe
patreon exists
click notification bells bye